[Music]  [Music]  how's she doing  she barely speaks to me i don't need  your sympathy uncle john that mustang's  got a real mean streak  she's just angry she was rounded up and  taken away from her family  what's her name i haven't given her a  name yet i heard you lost your family  too  you really are beautiful  that's what i'll call you black beauty  you've gotten closer to that philly in  days than i have in weeks  they say horses pick you thank you the  rescues have a time limit you can't sell  anything  you're my family you know that right  [Music]  she saved my life you know how can a  horse save a person  [Music]  if i fought for every horse i'd ever  loved out of 100 of them  i don't want 100 horses i just want one  [Music]  you